si vous êtes harcelés dans la rue vous
pouvez entrer dans un commerce et
obtenir de l'aide discrètement grâce à
un nom de code comment en demandant à
parler à angela ce dispositif est
proposé dans les commerces bars hôtels
restaurants ou établissements de nuit
ayant le sticker ici demander angela sur
leur devanture inspirée d'une initiative
mise en place au royaume uni en 2016
demande et angela est déjà en vigueur
depuis plusieurs mois dans dix villes
françaises comme bordeaux lyon rouen
caen ou encore nine et continue de
s'étendre les commerçants sont formés en
amont par le planning familial à
recueillir la parole d'une victime de
façon bienveillante sans jugement et
sans discrimination ils pourront aller
jusqu'à appeler les secours si
nécessaire